You didn't see that coming
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new avengers Wandavision video we got a
big announcement about quicksilver i know a lot
of people wondering if he's going to show up in
the series so we'll break it all down there are
even a couple more promos that they released in
latin america that i'll play during the video
just hyping it up before the end of the year if
you're new to the channel i'll be doing videos
for all those episodes when they release so be
sure to subscribe to get those we'll do a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know what kind
of x-men easter eggs you want to see show up in
the episodes i'll just number these as we go along
to stay organized but starting with the big stuff
recently a reporter at emerald city comic con
spotted listings for Wandavision toys that
included quicksilver he reportedly spotted
a two pack for vision and quicksilver pops
prototypes for some of the marvel disney plus
toys have also been leaking out for some of the
other series like falcon and winter soldier so
if you didn't know marvel will be selling toys
based on the disney plus series obviously
that's a big part of the avengers movies
all the mcu movies selling toys makes way
more money than releasing the actual movies
interesting there's no um thor toy in here it's
not really a big deal for them to sell quicksilver
toys but this is an aaron taylor johnson looking
quicksilver toy it's new and it's branded is a
Wandavision toy as if he's showing up on the
series so quicksilver himself being part of
their toy marketing does line up with some earlier
casting leaks from this past year when some videos
of auditions for two of their twin boys playing
wiccan and speed were spotted that reference
quicksilver the videos got taken down pretty
quickly as you would assume but they were for two
younger adolescent boys one of them was talking
to the other in the scene that had leaked out they
were worried about waking their uncle up who was
sleeping in the next room on the living room couch
and because we knew that they were doing scarlet
witch and visions twin children from the comics
as you see during the trailer wiccan and speed big
x-men characters the uncle they referenced had to
be quicksilver because vision doesn't have any
family and quicksilver is scarlett witch's only
brother there weren't any big reports of aaron
taylor johnson being spotted on the outdoor sets
of Wandavision when they were filming so they
could be getting really trippy with the way they
referenced him on the show if you remember
a couple years ago there were even reports
of aaron taylor johnson being spotted on the set
of avengers end game at avengers infinity war so
people thought that he might appear at some point
during that big crowd shot of avengers end game
presumably when the hulk snapped everyone back
maybe the russos thought about including him
in the big crowd shot like they talked about
including nova in avengers infinity war and
avengers end game there were probably a bunch of
other characters like quicksilver that they talked
about bringing back but if you think about it
on Wandavision it totally makes sense because he
died vision died the whole reason she's creating
this tv-based alternate reality bubble dimension
is to live out a version of her life where vision
is alive and they can have the family that she
always wanted to have but never could and in
that perfect reality her brother would also
probably still be alive i know a lot of people
are wondering if she's going to try and bring
vision back to the main mcu reality like save him
because this is clearly a fake version of vision
but i think a big part of them doing Wandavision
the series is that it's told from her perspective
like it's wanda's vision but it's also Wandavision
as in the tv show theme that they're going with so
i think it's all about her catharsis and her
getting some closure over vision's death so i
think it's pretty even odds as to whether or not
they bring vision back to life in the main mcu
reality because he is an android technically
shuri was supposed to be able to revive him
like you fix the machine you should be able to
bring him back it was just a question of what
he was going to be like without the mind stone if
your long time marvel comic book fan for some of
the old stuff you might also see some of the white
vision comic book references they're making with
this black and white stuff the joke there is that
the white version of vision that they brought back
was after he had been destroyed but they brought
him back without the mental patterns of wonder
man so he basically had no personality he was
this cold unfeeling robot so even though they're
referencing a lot of these classic tv series
from the black and white era of television
they're also kind of referencing the version
of vision from the comics that came back
looking all white and had zero personality during
the scene where the kids were auditioning talking
about quicksilver it didn't reference what decade
it was in but if you look at it here this looks
like the 80s decade of television sitcoms so
they wouldn't be adolescents till the roseanne
90s era which is this scene right here where she's
got her hands on her hips like she's really upset
with them they just did something really bad
the really interesting thing though about this
is if you look at the scene from the trailer where
you see her in black and white on the old tv set
inside a black and white room like we're standing
in a black and white room watching her in a black
and white television show she answers the phone
vision residence while we're watching her on tv
but then a full-color version of her looks like
she gets sucked into the alternate reality tv
dimension in her street clothes modern day street
clothes and sees vision greeting her saying
wanda and it looks like her jaw is about to hit
the floor like she can't believe what's happening
we know that agatha harkness is a big character
on the series because of the subtitles from the
marvel version of the trailer thank you very much
person that did the subtitles agatha harkness is
also a powerful magic user or a sorceress like
dr strange she could be manipulating scarlet
witch into using her powers to create this fake
reality agatha harkness has been both a mentor
and a villain to scarlet witch in the comics so
it seems like based on the trailer footage she's
playing both her and vision just totally messing
with them in a kind of sadistic way like telling
vision that he's supposed to be dead since a
lot of their halloween costumes are meant to
be big comic book references she's dressed like a
witch i think that's just her dressing like comic
book act at the harkness and if you think about
the earlier scene where things start to glitch
out it's almost as if vision comes back to life
without his memories of avengers infinity war and
being killed by thanos but he starts to remember
maybe and that's when things start to glitch out
then you start to get the bigger house of m easter
eggs from the comics where she also created an
alternate reality which then starts to crumble
around her where she does her no more mutants line
it kind of seems like a version of that is
playing out in these scenes here with the
reality sort of cracking and crumbling around
her so even if quicksilver is coming back that
doesn't necessarily confirm that aaron taylor
johnson is coming back or that they'll bring him
back into the main mcu reality remember this is
a version of reality where she can make anything
she wants reality so they could be featuring him
as just part of the story or reference him as
if he's still alive and visiting them during one
of the decades of sitcoms they're living through
and that winds up being it they didn't really
say how fast they're blowing through each of
those decades either originally the series is only
supposed to be six episodes and there were rumors
they could be doing more than six but paul bettany
said the way they paced pasted out is that the
first half of the episodes were going to be doing
the weird sitcom reality stuff and by the second
half of the series the show turns into a big
avengers level movie with tons of action scenes
like things go avengers level crazy which is
probably where they start to get into all the
nick fury sword stuff and doctor strange 2
movie crossover the early theory there is that
eventually scarlet witch is going to try and save
fake vision in her fake children just like in the
comics and bring them to the main mcu dimension
while also having a full-blown wizard battle with
agatha harkness and any other potential villain
the act of the hardness might be working with
the same way that kaiselius was the villain of
the doctor strange movie but really he was just
a puppet for dormammu i don't think the ag of the
harkness is working for dormammu necessarily i
think they'll try to introduce some other new mcu
villain the reports from a couple years ago were
that nightmare was going to be the main villain of
doctor strange too but since sam raimi became the
director they could have changed that there are
a couple really big supernatural villains that
doctor strange and scarlet witch share mephisto is
probably the other biggest one that they haven't
quite done in the mcu yet even though they did
reference him during the original avengers movie
his big connection to her is through her children
the promos that they released recently were just
for latin america so they just have like a quick
voice over of her saying welcome latin america
we invite you to watch Wandavision on disney plus
so it's not a really big trailer or anything like
that they also did the same thing for falcon and
winter soldier like hey latin america please watch
our shows on disney plus when it launches in
your country but kat dennings who plays the
darcy character in the thor movies is also going
to be a character on the Wandavision series she
did an interview recently just confirming that
marvel is trying to get the series out by the
end of the year further supporting the theory
that it's going to be released in december
and not earlier as some rumors were claiming
the actors themselves genuinely have no idea
when the episodes will start but that's only
because marvel is still racing to finish special
effects in post-production and they don't know
when they're going to be finished with that
that was the big hold up earlier this year it was
the same problem with falcon and winter soldier
like they had some big action scenes and crowd
scenes that they had to film those need a bunch
of special effects so because they had to delay
filming those for several months and now they're
working on the post-production for those it's just
a matter of them racing to complete the rest of
that footage but there will be at least one more
Wandavision trailer maybe around thanksgiving with
some different footage and then maybe a falcon
and winter soldier trailer sometime in december
that really just depends on when marvel wants to
release that series i know there's all kinds of
theories about falcon and winter soldier spoiling
some of the things that happened in the black
widow post-credits scene most people believing
that there's some thunderbolt stuff happening
during the black widow movie but if they release
any other big details or we learned anything about
those series of course i'll do a new video my
next big video is going to be for the mandalorian
season 2 episode 2 that'll be up friday just like
normal as long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that when i post it while
you wait for everything click here for my full
mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video and click
here for my avengers Wandavision trailer video in
x-men easter eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!